Let's go next to why don't we go to Edgar
from Florida. Edgar, you're on the air.
She doesn't think so, Atika.
We're going to have to do
something about about your audio.
Oh, yeah, OK, no problem.
That's much better. Yeah, very quick fix.
Awesome. So I just wanted to ask your
opinion on basically how Latin America
deals with their own racial spectrum. I feel
like a lot of the times in America who sorry
people may have an underrated observation of race
relations between, you know, for example, Afro
Colombian, African Colombians and, you know, white
Colombians, for example. Yes. And for example,
in some countries, there's a lot of like there's
a big African Colombian maybe or or or Ecuadorian
population, but maybe not so much in, for example,
Argentina. Correct me if I'm wrong. Maybe you're
absolutely right. You're absolutely right.
No, this is a super important issue. Edgar,
I know that there are some people on the left who
want to believe the U.S. is like the most racist
country. And we just it's just it's disastrous
racism. We have problems with race in the United
States. That is both individual racism. It's
also structural racism and the after effects
of structural racism that have not yet been
resolved and the inequalities they deal with.
But some of the stuff that goes on, there are
many countries that are much more racist than
the United States. And now I'm not saying
Argentina is the most racist country,
but because I know Argentina, because I was born
there. Attitude there. First of all, there's
almost no what we in the U.S. would call black
folks down there. They often refer to black people
who are just like more what we would call native
or mixed populations. They refer to them as black
and often in pejorative terms. There is a lack of
even understanding, like I remember family members
of mine who don't even realize that the way
they're saying it is sort of strange would say,
what is it like with the president being black in
the United States? And I would be like, I don't
know, I didn't really think about it in those
terms. It's sort of just like there's a president.
So that's that's Argentina. And there's a lot of
other examples I could tell you. There are many
countries where the issues of racism, we could
say they're worse or not as bad or just different
than in the US. But the US is not, you know, the
the worst offender of racism. The U.S. has tons
of people. The U.S. has a horrible history of
racism that's codified in law. And these these
are terrible things. And we're still working
to fix them. And there's much work to be done.
But it's not unique to the United States.
Absolutely. I agree. Wow. Thanks so much,
Dave. And if I could ask one quick little extra
question. Sure. You identify as basically a white
Jewish person or or as Argentinean. How would
you kind of word that yourself? Because I have
an Argentinean friend. Yeah. Who his girlfriend,
like, you know, kind of told him about your wife,
like ethnically or like, you know, whatever.
You look like a white guy. And he took
offense to that, like, no, I'm Argentinean.
Oh. You know, here's what's really funny about
that. By the U.S. Census definitions, I'm I'm
certainly Hispanic. There's no question about
that, because that's. And you can be white and
Hispanic or non white and Hispanic. So by the
U.S. Census, I'm absolutely Hispanic. I also am,
in a sense, a white guy and that people see me
as as a white guy. And I learned English young
enough that I don't have an accent in English
except when I'm deliberately mispronouncing words
for the lulls. You understand. OK, up. But then
there's another funny thing, which is really
my ethnicity is is Ashkenazi Jewish. Like when
I do my DNA test, it doesn't come back, you know,
European, German, French, it comes back Ashkenazi
Jewish white supremacists don't see me as white.
Now, why I care what they see me as maybe is a
different question for a different day. But the
bottom line is I identify as a white Hispanic.
That's that's the way that I mostly see myself.
Same here, but. Yeah. Oh, and they appreciate
the time, David. All right. And you're from
Florida. Powerful phone call. Very, very exciting.